hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
Donald Humphrey we're gonna watch from
the channel lantern 28 okay I'm sure we
flash it on screen so this is called
Justice League was three films I'm not
exactly sure what this is one of our top
of our tears our patreon page is
whatever video is requested we must
doing put up on YouTube and today comes
from Lance door our handsome fireman
Canadian from Canada and the description
says Kevin Smith has learned new
information about the fable Snyder cut
of Justice League and it's a huge
bombshell
it's a Powerman 5000 song so I think
he's just talking that my video just I
love listening to Kevin Smith talked to
I like his interviews and podcasts and
general Susie azzam I like that more
than his films honestly so I would I can
listen to this guy forever
so yeah let's let's check this out let's
see what information he's got the
download long I'm not first will forever
be talked about this night who worked on
Cruz in movies that shoot me okay Star
Wars doing things which is not just
students ladies ladies people in general
yes
given be work in the British film
industry which includes not just
so this is not on Star Wars time you're
done okay it's always a lunchtime oh
[ __ ] you'll love this so you get to find
out from other players involved you
forget there's always there regardless
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
they saw Gimli breakdown boards for all
three Justice League three okay Zacks
going to Barker's was kind of what we
saw find Steppenwolf
meet the wolf then like the [ __ ] boom
- opened up and they saw dark side and
dark side saw them there was a
your target moving to closes that's the
end of the movement them all knowing
there's something out there we have to
go Justice League to was going cosmic as
they take the fight to apocalypse and
the lantern wow they're artisans do you
remember
yeah guy I met talked to worked on the
set was like we had to end like Empire
Strikes Back or infinity so they go to
space then get [ __ ] defeated and dark
side goes to earth and levels so the
vision that talked about it yes where he
saw the [ __ ] story was going to be
the entire third movie the hero's last
stand against Darkseid and the forces of
the poppers that's cool that is that's
pretty fast
holy [ __ ]
and then it went away so left from three
movies to they would have ended their
university they really I really miss it
actually all lines up there was a vision
it was planned out they had people he
saw well Jim he drew it out he's like so
you can see and these cats are in
special effects so they saw the people
like the story and that that was an epic
vision when it sounds like
they were
[Music]
[Laughter]
and they said there's so much Jason
now that Aquaman is a billion kajillion
dollars he can say that keep breaking in
the bill for the W people like you you
can say do all the weird stuff problem I
mean he's so charming to probably be
just fine if you spoke oh man a lot of
times I hear like crazy ideas about what
they were trying to do and this is all
in tune with things I've heard before
this is more than what I've heard before
yeah actually hearing the whole thing of
how plays out it made me go oh now it's
now it's all complete like from all the
Nuggets I've heard from here in this
YouTube video and then this article seen
in BBS this seemed to have nothing to do
with Justice League yeah yeah the whole
dream sequence and then hearing
everything he heard that made me go
I see yeah all that all the dots have
now connected from everything I've heard
that must have been the original version
and while that does sound cool in theory
I feel like ultimately with the road
they were headed down
I don't mind dark I feel like the vision
and the concept is cooler than probably
what the execution might have given us
that's this sense I got because I am too
fascinated by the way these movies have
gone and part of it is got to - who's
laid on my shoulder yeah I don't know
because I'm not against dark subject
matter I'm not against even the idea of
things that are bleak I just think you
have to handle it in a proper way
but yeah I mean I think destroying all
of the earth is kind of like a whoa like
that's a kind of a tall order because
that's also doubling down they did
infinity war they drop infinity war if
they didn't infinity war like three
movies like wow that was fast
yeah we got here really quick yeah what
was the original plan for that was it to
come out with a Justice League sequel
pretty quick yeah I mean I mean I had
always heard what was announced was
Justice League part 1 and part 2 which
was supposed to be Steppenwolf then
Darkseid hmm they're the Darkseid thing
and and really enough I'd heard the
Green Lantern thing before yeah I heard
I heard the Green Lantern Theory before
yeah that was supposed to be him in that
moment yeah but even still like oh wow
all that sounds really cool on paper
even if Green Lantern was to be in the
first Justice League movie that whole
Hope line yeah where would any of that
plotline have fit that properly build-up
Green Lantern and set up Green Lantern
for audiences you know like the Ryan
Reynolds one was and what they were
gonna be doing and you would have to
reintroduce and the flop so you couldn't
just like people were you can't just do
that yeah that's I mean like all this
sounds really cool like that I've I
heard they made this animated trilogy of
Justice League I would be like yeah I'd
watch that that sounds cool but for the
big live action movie goes like that's
something you got a
bill - yeah you could have done these
three but I feel like later down the
road is what they probably should have
done yeah yeah I would definitely agree
with that just enough time for them to
solidify the tone of their franchise and
I guess going back before to finish that
point is like I don't mind bleak stuff
as long as there is something happening
underneath it or a reward for that
basically they just sounded like one
bleak journey it feels very at least and
this is just a vague description of
things heard like ìyeah thinking with
the images like oh man this sounds crazy
yeah it's really cool but then I think
okay but then earth is destroyed and
it's just like a couple heroes and them
just what happens when they're done they
just done and and the earth sucks yeah I
mean like it sounds cool it sounds like
there was a specific vision for it but
based on that's why I say yeah yeah
because if you do an animated movie I
feel like there's more leeway for that
you know because you handle that a
little differently you can be a little
bit more exposition all those things you
can get away with for the animated
straight-to-dvd kind of movie yeah then
you can't really do with the live-action
medium and also just with the current
iteration of what like for Man of Steel
the BVS and the way BVS was ultimately
received and justice like I've heard for
many people say there is no Snyder cut
because even here they were saying that
like Kenneth Smith was talking about
drawing boards scripts but not he was I
didn't hear him referencing things that
were I know there was a plenty shot that
was never converted through the visual
effects Department or the editing
Department and that all costs millions a
la dollars more you know yeah so I don't
think there is a Snyder cut waiting in a
vault there's probably enough footage to
make I feel like there's footage to
throw down a lot more money to put
something together but ultimately I feel
like we'd still be left with a Snyder
cut of a part one yeah especially if he
is what he's saying is because I was
always like even if there was a Snyder
cut it would just be a part one it still
wouldn't feel like a complete JL movie
but now hearing this I'm like oh so just
be a Snyder if they're all his money
to make a Schneider cut of a part one to
a three part never see the white parts
as cool of you to see that footage I
mean I'd be down to even just see like
the [ __ ] they shot as opposed to I'm
having to see like a whole edited film
IV down and be like yeah at least that
footage of the black Superman suit and
all that I feel like that would be a
decent compromises I think I think that
would also maybe say it a lot of
people's appetites is to at least see
the footage cuz you can fill in the
effects yourself if you want to you know
well I think the man for the Schneider
cut has gone it's still there but I
think it's gone down more considering
the success that DC has landed
themselves and I feel like when the
trailers for Aquaman and both Shazam
debuted that was smart on the comic-con
spectrum for the marketing because you
had a look at two very different films
to drastically different because Justice
League sort of felt like a studio exact
as much as I like that movie he I've
done a whole video of like why I love
Justice League as much as I really love
that film
I just feel the studio notes all over
that yeah I have tone of reaction to
what people thought the prior
installment yeah whereas with the
success of what they've done with
Aquaman like their biggest hit the
biggest DC film ever is that crazy
it is to go from a lot of Justice League
all with the DC universes and the
biggest trouble has ever been into oh
then we have the most successful you
oblique shot at that [ __ ] he's done
arguably the least necessary character
in the Justice yeah that's gnarly to me
yeah and all the time of filming this
the early reactions is Shazam are out
and I have yet to find a negative thing
said about that from everyone who was
able to take part of that social media
embargo everyone is like I love this
yeah and you watch the trailers and
you're like I'm having a really hard
time believing that this could be bad
yeah yeah yeah when I think that for at
least a certain amount of people who are
very invested in DC perhaps that is part
of the drive it's maybe it's not even so
much about the
Schneider cut like arguably it would
have been a more cohesive film for
Justice League but I think certain
people are probably just really excited
that DC finally has found at least a few
things that really do work and the
people the general populace included
bandying around and praising and stuff
you know I really feel like if Joaquin
Phoenix's joke or film does well because
literally what they like John and I
really believe in the rule of three
Jordan Peele got one more to go you got
one more to go yes Larry and like you do
three good in a row you're really a stat
like that goes for actors that goes for
directors that goes for these movies you
were active yeah there's like you're
okay not two but three proves like a
real consistency if you get too good in
a shaky three you got to start all over
it's usually I go that's the way it's a
sad part of how it goes yeah look at em
nice so with the three here if they get
Joker down I feel like well they'll be
even way less people talking about the
Snider cut after Aquaman a lot of people
if DC finds ya cuz I don't know we're
supposed to be this the fans read
center-cut is the Savior yeah exactly
this is the hidden gem this is the great
thing that they have hidden gave us all
this time yeah yeah so that's why and
now they've proven themselves capable of
quality beyond that and yes not tied to
Jos sweet yeah this is a fascinating
video thanks Lance door for requesting
this buddy yeah last time we were
talking to messages he was talking about
when he wants to travel to America he
wants to buy us a beer Oh
beers was beers with a fireman yeah I
would feel very not masculine I mean
what I want to do is set my house on
fire because aunt Esther like swooped in
this suit yeah
I'll kill the fireman in the nearby
district it's that way you'll be like
we're out of fireman what do we do you
gotta get here the hose he brought on
the plane to America rammed hose all
Canadian firefighters carry their own
fire
how's within ever they go even he goes
there and unsuccessfully puts out the
fire dies in it and has to say goodbye
to his child
oh man I'm fine why would you do this
really bye I like black fires that black
fired black
I like Bleek Bleek Bleek Bleek is good
so it was great
hey wait Lance thanks for requesting
this all right well you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and last thing I
love how they were set up for this
Batman and Batman
they're here the crowd is over there and
they're at each other the whole crowds
over there yeah actually I would love to
go to one of these sometime because they
shoot him just do you think they play to
their audience a little bit maybe maybe
the camera is right over here yeah I
didn't even realize that until just
looking here now but yeah it looks like
who you just watched the show in the
whole time I was watching I'm like oh
man yeah this is why with YouTube videos
is important look at you guys